I know you Russell you do jujitsu and
you're into nutrition I am I am this
outside crew was affiliated with the
group the Titanic don't you're connected
also to one of the America's Heroes
Muhammad Ali oh yes yes my service to
others is the rent we pay here on earth
and hard work and also compassion and
caring about people right we're in this
together that's right we got the next
mayor in the city
Jerry Joyce here on the D show don't go
anywhere greens a piece welcome to the
Dee's show and I got potentially our
future mayor Jerry Joyce in the studio
how are you mr. joy I'm doing great
thank you for having me very nice to
meet you how you been I'm doing great
I'm doing great
we were just throwing around a little
bit about before we started I hear
because we want to get to know you a
little bit and I know you Russell you do
jujitsu and you're into nutrition I am I
am more so now than ever in my life
fortunately societies societies much
more into nutrition now than ever when
we were kids at least when I was a kid
so I've learned a lot more about it I
need to do better in my own eating
habits but a lot more knowledge out
there a lot more information out there
about what everyone and I've come to
learn just based on personal experience
how important and how impactful
nutrition is and what you eat is to just
I feel everyday let alone your overall
health yeah they say 95% of chronic
diseases are related to the health
choices the food choices that we make I
mean just to get into like say the you
know cancer one in two men one in three
women expecting to have cancer so you
got chronic health issues through the
roof obesity 70% diabetes and I it's
it's crazy you know so it's good to see
you know because a lot of times you see
unfortunately people who are it says
something a lot we know wrestlers in and
themselves you know athletes especially
wrestler
are really hard workers and have really
good work ethic they definitely do it
isn't most athletes are but yeah so now
when we get into somewhat and you could
connect that to let's say someone
tomorrow who will be in public office
right that this also helps to have you
know clear mind clear thought you know
what I mean
taking care of themselves if someone's
taking care in their body taking care of
themselves also this helps to make a
complete holistic human being I agree
with that an athletic training and and
all that brings is uh there's another
facet that will be helpful in the
mayor's office yeah let me what let's do
I want to do a reaction video okay let
you get your feedback I think how's that
great that's a mac-10 a semi-automatic
weapon originally designed for military
use and illegal in Chicago so why do you
need guns down the fire protect the
dangers alia this Southside crew was
affiliated with the group the Titanic
stones they covered their faces to
conceal their identities they actually
told us they hate guns i mr Joyce what
is your reaction when you see something
like that in what have you heard this
term used for our wonderful city chiraq
I have you heard that term and let's
start with my reaction to that it's on
different levels
so to see teenagers or young adults
sitting around with automatic weapons in
masked faces and talking about how they
need it for protection is disheartening
disgusting on some levels abhorrent not
I don't buy into totally what the
dialogue that was going on there but
nonetheless obviously they're in a
lifestyle that they are at this point
committed to which centers around
violence
I don't think protection is is the only
reason they're carrying guns in that
situation right there
I do understand in too many
neighborhoods in Chicago that guns are
carried for protection and having over
exposure to that and the reasons for
that is a very detrimental very
detrimental thing on all Chicagoans the
youth that are exposed to that and as
they grow older it gets to a point where
there's unfortunately probably no
turning back in too many instances
practically speaking yeah so one of the
things I want to do is address the not
the symptom not the symptoms but the
causes of what leads to a life of
violence and do that in early age
provide alternative opportunities
alternative pathways positive experience
a positive role my house there's not
enough of that going on in our city
right now at least not throughout
mm-hmm so in anybody's in Chicago or
anywhere else is walking around with
automatic weapons on the streets of an
urban area there's there's no excuse for
that that's unacceptable should not be
tolerated but it's it's it's a say in
that term chiraq that's that's terrible
no no no Chicago one should be should be
proud of that or happy to repeat it
dumped it and all the reasons associated
with it and that that is so
so sad that nationwide we are known that
way there's so many people whether it's
well now it we're known as either the
murder capital or this violent city for
now most Krupp city in America so
neither of those are titles that
Chicagoans want to have or be associated
with and neither of those are things I'm
going to tolerate as mayor yeah I like
what you said going to the root cause
getting down to you know because you see
uh what touch me about that is that
obviously that's not acceptable but
going towards the root because you have
what what can can can we do where you
have broken homes when you have broken
home broken societies and you know to
see where you know some programs can be
set for those different disenfranchised
kids for the for the youth you know to
get them off the street you know to you
know because I heard a statement I
interviewed a former NFL player and he
brought this up from one of his friends
that you can't beat ignorance out of
someone with a stick you know I mean
force is not always you know the answer
you know there's a lot of deep-rooted
problem I like what you said getting
down to the root of these issues right
it's the only way to affect this problem
and the evidence is there give it a
history well how far we gotten dealing
with these issues so we need to try
different things and need to emphasize
things that have been things that are
working and are being done right now but
they're not giving the proper resource
proper banking proper coordination and
that's one of the things that mayor that
I've been saying I would want to do
public safety is my number-one issue as
a candidate and as mayor because we can
get it right in every other level
if we fail on public safety Chicago
doesn't have a future
yeah and Public Safety has the law
enforcement component but it has so much
more to and that's what we're talking
about right now and that's what I
brought that up because it's something
that's one one of the number one things
on the list right tell us more about you
you're connected also to one of the
Americas heroes Muhammad Ali oh yes yes
my sister-in-law Jamila is uh Muhammad
Ali's daughter she's married my brother
Mike they have three children Nadia a
mayor
and Jake they live about a mile from us
or well blessed to have them so close
and in our lives
Jamilah is about not about I have to say
the nicest person you could ever meet
and that's that's not an exaggeration
there's anybody who meets her who knows
her is just blown away how nice she is
she's the most and I know a lot of nice
compassionate people out there but she
takes the cake and uh and she's her twin
sister she's an identical twin her
sister Rashida is uh it's also wonderful
and they're identical in so many ways so
yeah it's uh it's been a blessing for
our family to have them a part of our
family well tell us more about this
yourself getting to know you mr. Joyce
for the people out there you you you
talk about or it's it's known that your
mentor to kids you also adopted several
kids of your own can you tell us about
this well my wife and I have four
children my wife Jeanine yeah we have
four children
we their adopted from Guatemala we've
had them since they were infants and we
are so blessed that my son Jeremiah is
18 our daughter Karina is 18
our son Christian is 11 our daughter
Caylee is 11 so we have a we're blessed
with a beautiful family and wonderful
beautiful children in so many ways I was
lucky to have a wonderful I was involved
in athletics growing up yeah extensively
and in that I had a lot of good coaches
wonderful people that through their
experience I learned commitment and hard
work and also compassion and caring
about people just following their
examples I know coaching and mentoring
and things like that take a lot of time
and it takes sacrifice is because you're
doing that and lose something else yeah
and and these are people that had their
own families too so that really I really
appreciate that it hit a chord with me
and so I've always had an appreciation
for coaches and mentors and people that
are involved with kids always wanted to
do get involved that myself and I did do
that I I did coach high school football
and I coached wrestling and helped
start a wrestling program and did it was
involved I'm involved in mentoring and
mentorship programs and that is what I
would like to bring to the mayor's
office as well yes as we were just
talking about that all ties in helping
children at their most vulnerable at
their most impactful and at the most
effective point point when you can
because as these as things go along
problems get harder to solve and get
more expensive this out so just going
back for a minute when I think about
Mohammed Ali I know that over a quarter
of a million people were affected by
just his charity not only was he a hero
like for people a legend in the ring but
what really impacted people was who he
was outside of the ring how he gave back
and there's a famous quote of him
talking about the service Brens the rent
we pay here what is it again service to
others is the rent we pay here on earth
and this is when people are in those
positions of authority of that their
public that they hold Mayor be a
president whatever they have the biggest
responsibility now they have one of the
biggest responsibilities to make these
things happen
you know what is it to you when you hear
a quote like that comment well I grew up
knowing Muhammad Ali as a boxer yeah
quite honestly it wasn't till later in
life that I realized what a what a
humanitarian what a wonderful what a
great person is was the greatest and
that's that's apropos as far as elected
officials and people in public office I
do believe that that is a public trust
and that is entak awesome awesome
responsibility an awesome position to
first of all be honored by the election
the trust that people put in you for
those who are like to do in election and
then they too have the responsibility to
carry that out to abide by their wishes
to represent them I think that is a it's
virtually sacred I take that very
seriously and I hope I am elected and I
would I hope I can live up to the
representation and wishes of Chicagoans
where can people now they just got a
little bit of taste about about you
where can people if they want to learn
more about you and where can they look
you up what word we have a website is
Jerry Joyce 2019 com
we have seven days ago elections a week
it week away it's been a wonderful
experience we're hitting the ground
running here into the final week feel
good about things but turnout is a
question in these municipal races lately
so I urge one everybody to go to our
website and to if you like what we stand
for what I stand for how I want to lead
this city please please express that
likeness by coming out to vote thank you
very much hopefully thank you so much
for having you got great I appreciate
thank you so much and God willing that
if you're elected like we can always
remember you know what you were saying
that being in the service of people and
really giving back to make humanity
better to do our small small part to
really make a difference while we're on
this earth right we're in this together
that's for a difference thank you God
bless you can you do it yes thank you
thank you and thank you guys for tuning
into the Deen show we'll see every week
subscribe if you haven't already until
next time peace be with you
peace be with you